i
[Música]
ah
se desvanecen en italia las esperanzas
de recibir fondos europeos financiados
con deuda común en los próximos meses
fuentes comunitarias indican que esta
ayuda no llegará antes del próximo año
seguramente no antes del segundo
trimestre del 2020 de 21 y esto
claramente representa un problema
importante para el gobierno italiano que
necesita con urgencia esta ayuda para
salvar la economía italiana para
invertir en salud infraestructuras
ayudar al sector empresarial
italia recibirá de europa en total 209
mil millones de euros repartidos en 81
mil millones en subvenciones a fondo
perdido y 127 mil millones en créditos a
muy bajo costo de interés pero el país
deberá esperar al menos seis meses para
empezar a recibir esta ayuda y de aquí a
allá no es seguro que todas las
actividades productivas del país logren
sobrevivir
[Música]
según cálculos del banco central
europeo- portugal sería el cuarto país
más beneficiado con el fondo de
recuperación económica que fue aprobado
el pasado mes de julio por los líderes
europeos en un acuerdo calificado como
histórico lo anteceden croacia bulgaria
y grecia
recordemos que portugal es uno de los
países que mayor depende su producto
interno bruto del turismo que ha sido
una de las áreas más afectadas de los
390 mil millones de euros destinados a
este fondo que será repartido en calidad
de subsidios portugal estaría
beneficiado con 15.3 mil millones de
euros para inversiones en proyectos
ejecutar hasta 2026 en calidad de
préstamo en monto ascendería a unos 10.8
mil millones de euros recordemos que
estos fondos son condicionados la
comisión europea hace sugerencias a los
países y entre ellas está principalmente
contribuir a la que denominan la
transición verde y digital
portugal ha dicho querer ser uno de los
primeros países que entregue este
proyecto para su posterior discusión y
aprobación y así poder recibir estos
recursos a principios del 2021
[Música]
el presidente del gobierno pedro sánchez
anunció recientemente sus planes para
reflotar la economía española después de
la crisis económica desatada por la
pandemia según explicó sánchez el
ejecutivo pretende movilizar 72 mil
millones de euros de los fondos de
recuperación europeos con los que crear
800 mil puestos de trabajo en los
próximos tres años
el presidente desglosó también los tres
grandes grupos en lo que en los que
irían estas inversiones en un en un
primer lugar con más del 30 por ciento
de las inversiones se dedicarían a los
proyectos de la llamada economía verde
en un segundo lugar también más del 30
por ciento de los fondos se destinarían
a proyectos de digitalización y el otro
40% iría a proyectos de cohesión social
sin embargo estos tres grandes grupos se
subdividen en tipos de políticas entre
las cuales destacan las políticas
educativas científicas de inversión en
infraestructuras y en el desarrollo de
los rurales del medio rural que sufre
una importante despoblación sobre todo
en españa'
sin embargo a falta de que bruselas
validez este plan la sociedad española
se pregunta cómo se van a materializar
estos grandes anuncios
[Música]